Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sam from New York
City. Sam from New York City. You are next up,
what is on your mind today, my friend?
Sam from New York City, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me
Speaker 1: now I can.
Speaker 4: Awesome,
how are you doing? I just want to call and ask.
Another question about Afghanistan. I know you've
spoken a lot about it the past few days on
this show. Yes, I'm wondering. A year from now,
what would a successful mission look like to you?
Speaker 1: You're saying if we had delayed
this for a year or two, just what do I think?
Speaker 4: All right, I'm saying some stuff has
gone right. What's gone wrong the past few weeks?
If we look ahead to the summer of twenty
twenty two, given what we've already done,
what I believe you think Afghanistan
would look like a year from now
if the US foreign policy is successful,
Speaker 1: I think that the framing is completely
wrong. I think U.S. foreign policy has failed.
We've been there for 20 years. We did not create,
if we believe it was our
goal to create a sustainable
self governance infrastructure in Afghanistan,
we failed to do it. So U.S. foreign policy
has failed. The hope for Afghanistan would be
we get out, we deal with evacuating people,
our people, refugees. We figure out how to
empathetically take care of people that are
in a worse situation because we've been there for
20 years. And then in an ideal world, Afghanistan
goes in the opposite direction of being a failed
state. It goes in the direction of being a working
state, and there is peace and there is sensible
self governance. But the idea that we failed it
would be happening despite American
intervention, not as a result of it. And I,
I just disagree with the framing of that, because
we are our participation has been a disaster.
OK, Sam from New York City, apparently flummoxed
by my response, and so we're going to move on